i'm alex backus we got a lot of news
coming up for you we begin today with an
update on the case of jorge gomez
he was shot and killed after a black
lives matter protest it was last june
in downtown las vegas if you remember it
was a chaotic night
officer shaymi colonist was shot and
wounded just a few miles away in a
separate incident
well this morning the county held a
fact-finding review to provide a bit
more transparency
about an officer's use of deadly force
we have hector mejia
live from the clark county government
center right now with the very latest hi
hector
hey there alex and we should also
highlight this is not a trial right now
actually just minutes ago this public
fact-finding review
just ended and people are gathering
outside some key takeaways from earlier
this morning police say jorge gomez
carried
three guns but did not fire any of them
it's also becoming more
unclear whether he actually pointed a
gun at police
four officers fired 19 times none of
them had a body camera
both sides are now going through
surveillance video
and statements to try and clear up what
happened that night on june 1st of last
year
so we're told a final determination
about whether the district attorney's
office will file
charges against the officers will be
made in the coming weeks the four
officers reported fearing for their
lives
in their statements they claimed gomez
raised or leveled his gun
at them however when jason levitt the
lead investigator who gave a
presentation answered questions he said
he did not see gomez level a weapon
he later said that based on the video
it's quote indiscernible
whether the 25 year old pointed the
weapon
levitt did say that if gomez had
survived he'd face the following charges
four counts of assault with a deadly
weapon on a protected person
that's based on the officer's accounts
plus carrying a concealed weapon
investigators found a third gun in
gomez's bag and the last charge
possession of a short barreled rifle the
timeline of events laid out today
reported gomez was running northbound
when police opened fire
what you can't see that i'll identify
this video that's as good for that is
the red and blue lights that are behind
the tree that we can see through this
screen here
are the officers that were actually
involved in the shooting they were
further north
of mr gomez on the west side of the
street
according to investigators gomez's truck
was
towed to the gomez family attorney's
office
before police even had a chance to
search it with a warrant
while we were inside commissioned
chambers as the review was underway we
could hear the protests from outside
reverberating through the walls our 8
news now reporter victoria saha is live
continuing our
live team coverage she's right next to
the crowd with that part of the story
victoria
thanks hector protests outside the
county commission building remained
pretty calm for the morning
but one thing was pretty clear the
passion and need for justice was very
evident in their chance
that is one of the many chants we kept
hearing this morning friends and family
and
protesters firmly believe jorge gomez
did not deserve to be shot by metro
police officers 19 times
because they say he was running from
police and today nearly 10 months since
gomez's death protesters are pleading
for those officers involved
to be held accountable we're here for
his family
he deserves justice we want justice
because if this is happening to him this
could happen to any of our friends any
of our family
jorge gomez didn't deserve to die that
night and
he represents so many that have
[Music]
not only were the protesters calling for
the officers to be charged in gomez's
death but they said they wanted district
attorney steve wolfson
to be held accountable for not doing
enough to make sure the officers
are charged i do want to point out a few
protesters did bring up what happened
earlier this week in our country
another officer-involved shooting in the
case of dante wright and they say
enough is enough reporting for news 8
victoria saha